the whole part of the conversation is
like an open loop we have a bunch of
politicians that think in election
cycles and they're going to say the
right talking points because they pull
well and they're going to manipulate
people to vote for them but when push
comes to shove they're not investing in
the actual problem we need politicians
who invest in the problem they think
outside the box and not just in their
four-year election cycle
[Music]
we're proud to be police officers today
the nobility is gone we are now public
enemy number one we can't do anything
right we have keyboard warriors that
jump to conclusions with having half of
the information not even our political
circles really support us if it's not
politically expedient to do so
and i'm seeing the complete destruction
of my profession that i have that i have
fallen in love with there's a perfect
storm of reasons of why crime is
exploding in albuquerque you have high
crime you have high substance abuse you
have a weak on crime approach at the
state legislature we have since the
beginning of time
and then you couple that with a
completely handcuffed police department
eight years into a consent decree
that can't do their job for the citizens
of this community
and this is what you get the officers
get
you know they get in trouble if they
refer to it as this but the the public
refers to this is
the zone or the war zone we had an
uptick in shootings around 2009 to 2012.
that's what brought the doj to
albuquerque and they determined that the
city of albuquerque police department
had a pattern and practice of using
excessive force so that opened the door
for the department of justice in
washington dc to
basically
almost govern and be intricately
involved in everything this police
department does there's a list of
misdemeanor crimes and we're talking
prostitution drug paraphernalia
concealing id
um
possession of of drugs that are that
would be considered misdemeanor
shoplifting under a certain amount of
money
damage to private property where
officers have to carry around a cart if
you are if you are approached or you are
dealing with a circumstance that is on
that card you have to be able to
document and articulate in exigent
circumstance of why you're making the
arrest so the message to police officers
is don't arrest so your officers feel
like they're damned if they do and
they're damned if they don't they're
they're not able to do police work we're
already significantly understaffed and
now because of the policies
that we've created and some of them are
really ridiculous
we have less officers on the streets
protecting and serving this community
simply because they're following the
policy that exists i have seen entire
area commands where 50 000 people live
because of two uses of force just two
weeks ago
the whole area command was shut down
the all officers available to include
chain of command were investigating uses
of force being under resourced for
budgeted for 1200 we have right about
900
we've lost over 200 police officers in
the last two years
nobody's
like
lining up to be a cop nowadays because
the whole country and the scrutiny the
defund the police movement they just
don't feel supported so they have a
significant problem on their hands not
only in the city of albuquerque but
nationally
[Music]
you